الهام الفضاله وشهاب جوهر ثنائي في الحياه
منجم سوا على الشاشه في النون وما يعلمون
ودلال فتح الله تفجع العالم العربي وصاحبه
الشخصيه عندنا
وبين الزند وسفر برلك ومعهم الثمن كما
نانسي خوري نجمه في صعود وبقوه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
مسلسل النون وما يعلمون من الاعمال
الخليجيه البارزه في هذا الموسم الرمضاني
وهو عمل درامي بيعتمد على التشويق والغموض
والانتقام وكيف ان الانسان ياخذ حقه بيده
ممكن يوصله هذا التصرف المسلسل من بطوله
الهام الفضاله وشهاب جوهر وعبير احمد
وفاطمه الحوسني وغيرهم طبعا من الفنانين
ومن اخراج حمد سعيد البدري
[موسيقى]
ان اللي قاعده قدامك
فرقتيها هي واختها وامرهم عشر سنين انا
الحمل الكبير
وانا ريان خاف الله
[موسيقى]
علشان ولدت
هذه مو اول مره نشوف الزوجين مع بعض في
اعمال فنيه سبق وقبلها عمله سوا اعمال
عديده منها مثلا امينه حافه حلم امينه
حوبتي وغيرهم وفي النونو ما يعلمون
الثنائي الجميل الهام الفضاله وشهاب يلعب
بدور اخوه الهام بتكون فجر المراه
المتسلطه اللي بتاخد حقها بالانتقام
بلسانها وبيدها لكن شهاب بيكون اللي هو
براك اخوها بيبذل كل جهده على شان كذا
يهدي الاوضاع ويصلح اللي يقدر يصلحه
[موسيقى]
ان اللي قاعده قدامك
فرقتيها هي واختها وامرهم عشر سنين انا
الحمل الكبير
خلاك تراعدك
[موسيقى]
احترمي نفسك وتكلمي بادب
وينضم الينا من الكويت الثنائي شهاب جوهر
والهام الفضاله اهلا فيكم معانا منوريننا
اليوم
بعد قلبي منورين بوجودكم وكل عام وانتم
بخير ومبارك عليكم باقي الشهر وما باجي
على العيد تقريبا اقل من تسعه ايام نقول
لكم عيدكم مبارك مقدما
نتشرف باللقاء الجميل واول مره
دندراوي يعطيك العافيه ونقول لكم مبارك
عليكم ما تبغى من شهر وعسى الله يعودها
علينا بالصحه والعافيه جميعا وعلى امه
امين يا رب
السنه الماضيه نحن برضه كان عندنا لقاء
كان عن الجزء الثاني من امينه حاف وكان
بالضبط قبل سنه من الان فنحن يعني يبدو
هذا موعدنا كل سنه
بالضبط يعني صحيح
احنا نبغى اكثر زيارات اكثر نبغاوين كذا
طيب خليني ابتدي معاكي الهام هذا العمل
يعني بعد امينه حاف كان صعب انك تطلعي
بشيء مختلف او قلنا لازم الهام تطلع بشيء
مختلف وبالفعل هذا اللي عملتيه مختلف جدا
النون وما يعلمون اذا تقوليلنا عنه
الانتاج شهاب حبينا نطلع بصوره جديده
تراجدي
تحسين انك قاعد تتابعين المسلسلات
الرمضانيه الثقيله كوميدي والخفيفه اللي
الناس تحبها بعد الفطور حبيت اطلع في لون
مختلف ولله الحمد نجاح العمل واخذ المراكز
الاولى في الوطن العربي والخليج وحتى برا
المغتربين اللي في امريكا واستراليا
وبولندا وفرنسا اخذ مشاهده رقم واحد يعني
لله الحمد
رجاحي رجعته ان شاء الله برفعه راس ممتاز
وانا يعني اقدر مره صراحتك الهام في موضوع
الحديث عن امينه حاف وكيف انت تعلمتي من
الخطا حق الجزء الثاني يعني قليل ناس يعني
يقدروا يقولوا هذا الكلام فما بالك بفنانه
يعني من الصف الاول يعني طيب شهاب زي ما
ذكرت يعني الهام انا
بغيت اقول لك بالعكس انا هذا الشيء هذا
الشيء قلته انا اول مره احوله والفنان انا
دائما اقول بورصه بورصه سنه يصعد وسنه
ينزل وسنه تضييق الوقت تخليه يختار ناس
عشان يكون متواجد في رمضان فهذا حال
الدنيا مع الفنانين مو عيب ولا هو غلط
متعلم شهاب زي ما ذكرت الهام يعني المره
هذه الانتاج انتاجك والاشراف العام
كيف التجربه كانت
[موسيقى]
بعدين هنا دورها الحلو فيه انه لها دورين
للامانه يعني فكنا قاع نحاول بقدر
المستطاع ان اني اطلع الهام خصوصا بعد فشل
امينه حاب يعني حافوه انه يعني ماخذه نسبه
المشاهده اللي كنا نطمح لها مثل الجزء
الاول والاعمال السابقه والطوفان والى
اخره ونفس الحنين ايضا اللي كان بعد من
انتاجي شراكه
احدى الشركات
فقررت اني انا استقل بذاتي واني اشوف نص
يعني نقدر نرتقي فيه ليفل كبير وقوي واطلع
الهام بلون كبير وكان المسؤوليه وهواي
الثقيله علي لانك انت لازم اطلعها بصوره
مشرفه لانها امنت فيني
فالحمد لله يعني كنت قد هالثقه هذه اتوقع
كنت قد ثقه
استنى ترد عليك الهام تقول لك الموضوع
ههه
لانه لانه النجاح لا متعه كان وكلنا داشين
على رهان
يعني هذا كان يعني لازم الليفل كان يصعد
وخصوصا عقب اللي صار لازم كنا نقدم شيء
قوي
وازيد عليه انه شاب من كثر ما حريص علي في
في شركته حاليا اخذنا ثلاث نصوص شراها كل
نص اقوى من الثاني قاعد يختار النصوص
القويه مبكر وقاعد يشتريها ويخشها في
المكتب عشان ما يبي اي شيء ثقيله حلو
يطوفه ويطلع من ايده حاليا عندي ثلاث نصوص
كل واحد بعد اقوى من الثاني
بس هل نقدر نقول انه خلاص انتم الاثنين
صرتوا ثنائي لازم كل عمل حنشوفكم مع بعض
قرار انه راح يشتغل عمل رمضان عمل رمضاني
بس اما العمل الموسمي اي عمل موسمي ممكن
اكون انا بروحي مع نجم اخر
رمضان اللي هو
اللي الناس كلها تجتمع تشوف الاعمال واللي
الناس كلها تبي تكون في السباق الرمضاني
ان نجتمع في عمله في عمل رمضان لكن مو شرط
نكون كازواج او كحبيبين عادي طليق عادي
زوج عادي اخوي مثل هنا
كلام الهام بعد يعني وظيف على كلام الهام
باختصار شديد يعني انا تعمدت هذه النقطه
على اساس شنو انه حتى المشاهد ما يمل انه
نشوف اعمالنا كله مع بعض فهذه خطوه انا
خذيتها وكنت عند قراري ومثل ما صار ايضا
في نفس الحنين نفس الحنين انا ما كنت
وياها وجنات
فهذه مساله يعني انا قراءاتي للسوق اكتشفت
ان هذا هو الحاله الصحيه ان الهام ايضا
تشتغل وانا اشتغل ولكن قاعد نرتب اوراقنا
صوره حلوه والدليل على ذلك نفس الحنين كان
من انتاجي انا ما كنت متواجد فيك ممثل
ولكن كمنتج موجود الان كانت فيه بروحه
العمل دوري وياها دور اخوها
مستقبليه وما الى ذلك قبل فتره كان طلع
يعني خبر انكم انتم انفصلتوا بس ما شاء
الله يعني شكلها الامور جميله بينكم وان
شاء الله رمضان الجايه شايفينكم بعض
والكلام ده كله
هذا اول مره اسمع منك
قبل شهور كذا قبل شهور قبل شهور غاب شويه
شهاب عن سنابك يمكن فالناس على طول
احنا قاعد نصور باللوكيشن قال نصور بعضنا
هدف كان الهدف احنا ما نبي الناس تكون
متشبعه منه بشكل دائم فالهام ايضا لها
استقلاليتها انا اللي استقلال عليك زين
الشغل
يعني الظروف هي اللي تخلينا احنا مو من
النوع اللي نتعمد انه يلا تعالي نصور يعني
ما تبغى تتعاملوا مع بعض انكم كانكم من
الكابلز حق السوشيال ميديا
لا لا احنا مشى ساره
اول ايام يوم كنا نصور 24 ساعه
مطعم
شهر عسل الحين خلاص صار الوضع طبيعي متى
ما طلعنا طلعه حلوه صورنا حياتنا
اوكي طيب وصلت هذه الفكره بدي اسالكم كده
شويه اسئله بس على المواضيع هل عندكم
قضايا مرفوعه عليكم انتم رافعين قضايا على
احد
انا رافعه قضيه على مين
موجوده نفسها وفي المحاميه هي البستلمه
القضايا مالتنا اللي يعني في قانون ياخذ
مجرد
ايش التهمه في القضيه اللي ود اعشقك اخر
قضيه الشكوى اللي مقدمينه اخر قضيه كانت
تحريض الصحافه
اذكر الدوله تحريض صحافه خليجيه علي انا
في واتسابات بين الصحفي والشخص اللي عليه
الشخصة المعنيه قصدك القضيه
وحده وحده هي لانه طيب
يقال كمان وحده من الاتهامات اللي عليكم
بده يقال انكم انتم سبب في قطع رزق فنانه
وكثير بينكتب لكم هذه التعليق على
السوشيال ميديا
اعوذ بالله اعوذ بالله اول شيء قطع
الاعناق ولا قطع الارزاق وهذا كلش مو
مبدئي ولا من اخلاقي هذا شغله شغله ثانيه
بقول لك فيها ساره على هالسالفه انا دايما
اقول لهم هالموضوع لما نشوف بعض المقاطع
اظلموني او اقطعوا رزقي سالفه الرزق هذه
من الله لا بيجي ولا بيدك واللي بيظلم
يظلم نفسه من ايده هذي شغله شغله ثانيه
انا لو بطلب اقطع الرزق انا ترجيت عبد
الوهاب العيسى وهو حي يرزق موجود دشيت
مكتبه في بوتيكات وترجيته رجوى انه يدخلها
بوتيكات وكنت ماسكه تلفوني سنابها واقول
له اشوف شوفي شلون مسرحيتها شوف العرض
تكفى خلاص خلاص ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
ما دار يومين الا وقعوها بوتيكات ابسط
قطعه رزق يا ساره انا من التوب سيلفري
بوتيكات واول وحده وقعت عقد بوتيكات ولذي
كلمه مسموعه لله الحمد
لو انا بقطع هالرزق
بوتيكات وقطعت الرزق وقلت سكره واكلتها صح
ولا لا
دليل يعني لكن انا مو من هالشخصيات وابدا
وانا كله اقط ورا ظهري ترى ما يهمني انا
امشي سيده لانه لا حياتي فاضيه اني اداحي
فلان وفرنتان وانا مشغوله في بيتي واسرتي
وعيالي وعيالي شهاب
وامي واهلي وناسي الحياه الطبيعيه وشغلي
واعلاناتي انا مو فاضيه حق المشاكل وعوار
الراس واندرت ياخذ رزقه بالحياه
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني انا يمكن
شاهدتي مجروحه ولكن الهام من النوع اللي
تحب الخير الهام حتى يعني اللي يتجاوزه
وهذا تتقاضى مره مرتين ثلاثه عشر بعدين
تتقاضى بعدين
مثلا او يعني خلاص لازم تحط حد بالنهايه
عندها محاميه
احنا في الايام الفضيله ما احلف فيها كذب
والله العظيم انه بيني وبيني يعني في نفسي
وبيسمعوني اقول حتى ما صار في خط رجعه
ما اتركوا اثر جميل ان الواحد يرد وفيه خط
رجعه يعني
خلاص يعني ذاك اليوم نسولف حق شهاب اقول
له يمكن الغلطه الاولى اعديها الثانيه
اعديها الثالثه واسامح يصير بين الاهل
وبين الحبايب ماكو مشكله بس لكن في حدود
وفي خط رجعه تصير لكن الموضوع صار اوفر
انه خلاص
خلوا ما عندك خط الرجعه مستحيل قام قمت
تتخوفين منها لانها الناس يعني عند الله
بيننا وبين قطع الارزاق
وصلت يعني لو بسويها ابسطها لو بسويها كان
سويتها
بعدين منو احنا امام رب العالمين
في فنانه مشهوره من الفنانات الكويتيه مرت
في نفس الموقف ومعروفه يمكن تعرفينها توجه
لها تحيه كل ادب واخلاق قبل كم سنه صار
لها نفس الموقف وهذه هي لحد الان حالها من
حالها ما طلعت هذه الفنانه قالت انا ظلمت
انا طقيت انا ليش ما تكلمت عرفت قدر
مسؤوليتها وقدر الغلطه اللي هي سوتها
وقاعده الحين ساكته ولا تفتح باب ولا
سمعنا طقوها ولا سمعنا قالوا رزقها تحملت
غلطتها وقاعد تحاول تصحح وصلت وصلت
واقطع رزقك من دوله وصلت وجهه نظركم وطبعا
يعني الناس يعني عارفين انتم بتتكلموا عن
مين طبعا
وبامكانها هي لها حق الر د كمان
يعني ممكن هي كمان يعني ترفع قضيه او ما
الى ذلك بس انه على العموم شكرا لكم
منوريننا ورمضان كريم عليكم ومكسرين
الدنيا بالمسلسل كان معنا من الكويت يا
حبيبتي الله يسلمك
شكرا لكم
دلال بنت فتح الله ما ببالغ لو بقول ما
احد ما يعرفها بعد اللي عملته جعفر العمده
وصدمات الحلقات الماضيه دلال اللي بتلعب
دورها الفنانه ايمان العاصي هي الزوجه
الثانيه لجعفر العمده والزوجه ولكن هي
الحب الاول ودلال بتكون من الستات اللي
بسموهم يعني كده مستعده تعمل اي شيء عشان
تفضل هي اللي فايزه بقلب جعفر وبتكون كمان
طايحه بالنار اهلها ونار زوجها ولكنها
دائما بتختار زوجها
المسلسل من اول ايام وعامل حاله في الوطن
العربي كله وبكل شخصياته لكن في اخر
حلقتين تحديدا جرعه اهتمام الناس بدلال
تضاعفت فاست هانم دلال صدمت الجمهور وخيبت
امال كثار من المشاهدين اللي دايبين في
جمالها فمن بعد ما كانت على اساس حبيبته
المفضله عنده المظلومه وتايهه بن جعفر
واهلها اتضح انها عدوه وانهايه ورا خطف
ابنه اللي جعفر سيرلو سنين بيدور عليه
واللي المسلسل كله اصلا بيدور حوالين
حوالين انه احنا نلاقي الولد هذا من اول
يوم يعني لسان حال الناس من وقتها كان كل
ده يطلع مني كدلال
من القاهره تنضم الينا النجمه ايمان
العاصي اهلا فيك معنا يا ايمان ومبروك هذا
النجاح
اهلا ازيك عامله ايه كل سنه وانتم طيبين
والله يبارك فيك ازيك يا ساره عامله ايه
الحمد لله تمام منورتنا اليوم يعني ايمان
انتي جميله وبريئه وحبوبه وكلنا بنحبك
والكلام ده كله جيتي في دلال اول شيء
اقتنعنا انه وداد هي اسوا وحده في العالم
الان دلال تفوقت بمراحل يعني كيف متعامله
مع رده الفعل والصدمه تبعت الناس
بصي هو مش عارفه لسه اتعامل خالص قاعده في
البيت كده مستخبيه
قوي
بس انا مخدوده زي الناس بصراحه جدا
بس وصلتك رده فعل الناس وانهم زعلانين
والهجوم والكلام ده كله
هم الناس حابين قوي حسناء الشعبيه مسميين
الحسناء الشعبيه
وحابين قوي حاله الحب اللي ما بين دلال
وجعفر
وانه دلال دي الحضن الحنين بتاع جعفر واي
حاجه يترمي في حضن حنان دليل ويحكي لها كل
حاجه
في مره واحده دلال هي السبب الشوكه اللي
محطوطه بضهره طول العمر يعني
بس انت حتى انصدموا الناس جدا بس انا كمان
يعني يقال انك انت حتى متاثره بالشخصيه
حتى جوا البيت يعني في حاله خوف وقلق منك
يعني
مقصره جدا ههه
بس انت بتعمل الدور يعني يعني كنت متخيله
النجاح هذا
اه بصي هقول لك حاجه واحنا كده بدات لما
كنا بنقرا المسلسل وكنا بنعمل بروف
ات احنا بنصور
استاذ محمد سامي عنده طاقه كانت وهو دي
اللي كان بيزرعها كل ممثل في التيم
المسلسل كله ان احنا هننجح نجاح احنا قبل
كده ولا يعني قدامنا عشر سنين هنفضل نبقى
مبسوطين بالنجاح ده فانا كنت عارفه ان في
نجاح نجاح قوي جدا جدا ان شاء الله بس مش
متخيله بالنجاح العظيم احنا كل يوم عندنا
نجاح كل يوم عندنا حكايه كل يوم
بنسحب جمهور اكبر جمهور اكبر يعني الجمهور
بيكبر اكثر اكثر كل يوم فانا نجاحها عظيم
بس مش البهارده لا هو يعني
كل يوم ما شاء الله في الترند يعني
متصدرين بس انت كيف تم اختيارك في العمل
يعني لو انا من البدايه جيت تخيلتك في ده
الدور ما حلب بيجيك صراحه في هذا الدور
يعني
ما هي دي المشكله يعني حتى كان
اللجنه حبيبي وصاحبي محمد رمضان كان لسه
في انترفي بيقول ان انا دايما اهو قالها
لي في الاول فلما ابتدينا دايما بتحط في
دور الفيدات البنت الحلوه البنت
الرومانسيه البنت الكيوت فانا ده انا بعمل
لي عزمه كتير قوي وخليني اقعد كثير اتعطل
مش عايزه اشتغل لانه خلاص ما فيش ما فيش
حاجات تانيه ما في تحدي
الكيوت استاذ محمد سامي ده كان اختياره في
الاول انه انا اعمل دليل وانا اتخضيت بس
اتبسطت جدا جدا واتخمست وحسيت ان هو كان
يعني حاجه بدور عليها طول عمري من بدايه
مشواري الفني ولقيتها وبقيت ماسكه فيها
بكل يعني قوتي انه خلاص يعني دي فرصتي
استاذ محمد هو واجهه نظره وطبقها ومن اول
مره افكر فيها في ايمان تعمل دلال والحمد
لله يعني الحمد لله الحمد لله عملنا يعني
شغل كويس
لا لا ما شاء الله عليكم بس حتى بنتك علقت
على الموضوع يعني حطت بوست وكتبت قالت انه
يعني انا خايفه او او تعرفي خلينا نشوف
الكليب خلينا نشوف الكلب
[موسيقى]
الله يخلي لك هي بس يعني هي قالت انه يعني
انا كيف اعرف اذا انت خطفاني كمان ولا مش
خطفاني يعني البنت جالها حاله قلق يعني
ريتا بنتي مش من عدتها اصلا هي تعلق على
اي حاجه انا اشتغلتها وبقدمها وكده بس هي
ريتاج وبرضو مش من عادتها ان هي يعني سابع
حاجه طويله قوي كده يعني الجل ده بيزهق
بسرعه فتابعت المسلسل ومتابعاه
وقاعده طول الوقت تبصلي اللي هو يعني بجد
يا ماما انت خطفتي ابنه بجد انت عملتي كده
بجد انت الشريره قوي كده فهي ريتاج مصدومه
وتحاول يعني تخرج من فكره ان انا يعني
بحاول تخرج من فكره ان انا مامتها اللي
عملت كده وان هو ده تمثيل وبتاع بس هي مش
عارفه تركب معاها بتقول يا مامي انت
فضحتني في المدرسه ههه
والله يعني مسكينه طبعا اكيد بتاخذ كثير
تعليقات خصوصا كل الناس بتتابع المسلسل
طيب بدي اسالك يعني طيب اوكي انت خرجتي من
مثلا او شفناك في موضوع انه الكيوت ومالك
كيوت خرجتي منه والكلام ده كله بس ايش
رايك في موضوع انه قصه اربع زوجات هل مثلا
ممكن ايمان انت تعمليها في الحقيقه
الحقيقه اتجوز لا ما افتكرش انا ست غيوره
جدا جدا جدا يعني
عشان خالص خالص يعني خلاص يعني اه انا
مقتنعه ان هو حلل ربنا وكده وبس كل يعني
لا يكلف الله نفسا الا وسعها وهي بصراحه
يعني حاجه مستحيله بالنسبه لي جدا اكيد
اتعرض علي حاجات كتير شبه كده بس
ما تقدري حلو حلو حلو كويس انك انت عارفه
نفسك يعني غيره وما اقدر
اكيد طبعا الست اللي مش سعيده خلاص ما
بتقدر تسعد اللي معاها طيب على خير كمان
الاشياء اللي صارت في رمضان انت كمان
وقعتي في براثن رامز اتعورتي
ايش اللي صار
نهري قعد اسبوع يعني عندي وجع بس يعني مش
اتعورت يعني الحمد لله رجليا هو ما كانش
حاجه ما حصل ليش حاجه عظيمه الحمد لله
يعني بس يعني اه طبعا اتالمت وانا بلف في
الغساله يعني ههه يعني عظم ولحم يعني طب
وبعدين انت قلتي قلتي لرامز انه ما راح
اسامحك هل فعلا ما سامحتيه ولا خلاص
سامحتي
يا دعابه يعني
رامز من زمان جدا
واحنا اصحاب انا بحب رامز جدا جدا وخلاص
يعني احنا احنا اخذناه كده كله على بعضه
بجنانه
بتفكيره لما حدش بيتخيله
بحبه يعني لو زعلت وقتها لا على طول يعني
هو رامز مخلينيش امشي غير وانا مراضيني
يعني بس انا بحب ما بعرفش ازعل منه يعني
ولا في الحياه
الشخصيه برده بيعمل اكتر من كده في الحياه
يعني كمان
رامز حبيبي بيرحمنا في التليفزيون لا لا
لا لا لا لا لا لا من جد
ما كنتش هروح طبعا لو كنت عارفه ما كنتش
هتروحي انا ما فيش حاجه في الدنيا انا
بخاف جدا انا جبانه جدا جدا
فانا يعني حتى لو انا عايزه اروح لرامز
انا ما اعرفش رامز ممكن يعمل فيا ايه
الحقيقه لو كنت عارفه كنت واقفه مستحيل
اوكي فانت كنت عارفه انك انت رايحه مشاركه
انا هو ممكن يعني ممكن انا مثلا ابقى حظي
وحش لدرجه انه مثلا انا هبقى الضحيه
الحقيقيه بجد بقى يعني مش هيبقى مقلب
بسرعه قوي اوكي طيب ايمان انت منورتنا
اليوم يعني وما تتخيلي احنا كلنا هنا
بنتابع المسلسل وبنتمنى لك كل التوفيق
صراحه
والشيء الاضافي انه انت على ما يبدو واللي
فهمته انك انت في الايام الجايه حتكوني
اكثر شرا كمان لسه في يعني في صدمات والله
يا جماعه بصوا هي مش شريره ههه هي الشريره
ده كله امور شريره
قشطه عليك الشريره عندك يا ايمان
لا يا شريره
فرصتها طيب تبرعي طيب اوديها فرصتها كل
حاجه لها سبب صح ولا لا صح عندنا اسبوع
هنفهم فيه دوافعك الين اخر رمضان
طيب نورتينا يا ايمان
قاعدين قاعدين قاعدين احنا قاعدين معاكي
ونشوف ايش المبرر وبنشكرك جدا على ظهورك
معنا اليوم شكرا لك كانت معنا من القاهره
النجمه ايمان العاصي شكرا
باطلاله مقنعه نجحت الفنانه نانسي خوري في
اقناع المشاهد بشخصياتها اللي بتشارك فيها
في الموسم الرمضاني في كل من الزند
بالعاصي وسفر قدمت عفراء في الزند بتكون
اخت عاصي الزند اللي بيقوم طبعا بيدوروا
النجم تيم حسن والمسلسل بيلاقيني سبعه
عاليه مشاهدات عاليه او فيديوهات متصدره
المنصات من بدايه عرضه وعلى الرغم من انه
عفراء كانت نهايتها موجعه في الحلقه 12
وضحت بنفسها عشان تنقذ اخوها الا انها
قدرت تعمل بصمتها الخاصه في العمل
بشخصيتها اللي كانت فيها ام لطفلين وفتاري
فيها بسيطه تعرضت للظلم والقهر بعد مقتل
والدها وهروب اخوها وحقيقه المشهد وفاتها
من اكثر المشاهد اللي تفعل او تفاعلت معها
الناس وعنون وادائها بالرائع
اما في مسلسل سفر برلك فقدمت نانسي شخصيه
سمر الفتى السوريه اللي بتنتقل للعيش في
اسطنبول خلال فتره الاحتلال العثماني
تنتقم لوالده الطبيب اللي تم اغتياله فيه
ظروف مشبوهه سمر في المسلسلفه اعباء
الماضي وفي عندها نقمه على الحاضر وما شاء
الله غير العملين الضخمين اللي ناسي منجمه
فيهم كان عندها كمان عمل ثالث هو مسلسل
دوار شمالي وبتلعب فيه شخصيه وداد لكن تم
تاجيل عرض المسلسل لبعد رمضان بسبب ظروف
انتاجيه تنضم الينا من دمشق الفنانه نانسي
خوري اهلا فيك معانا يا نانسي منوره
هالرمضان
مساء الخير مساء الخير عليكم جميعا ورمضان
كريم وشكرا كثير على الاستضافه منوراتنا
علينا وعليك اول شيء خلينا بدي يعني
والسؤال اللي عند الكل اذا حنبدا من الزند
اللهجه يا نانسي اللهجه كثير ناس بيتكلموا
انك اجدتي اللهجه كيف
الحقيقه يعني سبقوا وحكيتا كنت عم بدرس
كنت عم احاول قد ما فيني اكون مجتهده باني
ادرس اللهجه لانه الحقيقه هي مثلها الواحد
عم يحكي لغه تانيه وهي كتير بعيده عني
قريبه من الله
فكان هيك تحدي كتير صعب بس انا برايي
الوقت يعني والممارسه تبع اللهجه مع الوقت
وبقلب فترات التصوير هي اللي كانت هيك شوي
شوي عم تصير اللهجه اقرب وصرنا نقدر
نحكيها اكثر بس بالحقيقه كانت صعبه بس
ممتعه كثير في نفس الوقت يعني الواحد لما
يكون مثلا بيسوي شيء او بيحاول يتعلم شيء
صعب فما بالك انه هو بيتكلم بلهجه ما هي
لهجته وفي نفس الوقت جلس يمثل قديش كان
صعب عليك التركيز يعني في الشيان يعني
كتير صعب اكيد اول فتره كان صعب بعدين مع
الوقت من كثر ما انا بعيد الجمل بيني وبين
حالي فخلص بصيروا مثل ما بيقولوا بيهضموا
من الممثل فبتصير بقى بيمثل كثير صعب وقت
كان يجتمع اكثر من لهجه مع بعض بنفس
المشهد بقى هذا كثير
كل واحد يحاول يركز بجمله لانه ممكن يجتمع
معك اللهجه اللي انا عم بحكيها مع اللهجه
مثلا شاميه بيضاء مع حمصي فهاد
مع بعض صحيح طيب صعب بس كان هيك
بتسلى وسافر لك مسويته او مصورته من قبل
سنتين يمكن او صورتيه في 2020 يمكن
تماما صورناه من السنتين تم تصويره اغلب
يعني اغلب تصويره صورناه بالقاهره بعدين
ببيروت من سنتين تقريبا
وانصدمتي السنه انه انعرض في نفس الوقت مع
الزند
تفاجات الحقيقه كتير تفاجات يعني كنت
ناطره عرضه على يعني طول الوقت يعني من
اول ما خلصنا تصوير كنا ناطرين ناطرين
العرض فانا تفاجات مثل الجموع وقت نزل
الاعلان طبعا
انه رح يطلع برمضان
فكنت سعيده بالحياه انه ينعرضوا العملين
بنفس الوقت اكيد فجاه لقيتي نفسك في عملين
ضخمين وفي رمضان في اهم موسم يعني
بيناتهم يعني لحتى انا الواحد كممثل بيكون
متغير عم شوف حالي هلا عم شوف ابن سنتين
كيف كنت عم بشتغل فغريب يعني كان الواحد
عم يحضر مو حاله عم يحضر حاله
ممتعه كمان وهيك من يومين خلصت الحلقه
الاخيره وفعلا كان عمل كثير يعني مهم وقوي
على كل القصيده الحقيقه هل التقيتي
بالراحه الحاتم علي لانه هو كان المسؤول
عن هذا العمل من البدايه
قبل رحيله يعني الله يرحمه والله يعني
ما لحن التقى فيه قبل التصوير لانه توفى
الاستاذ حاتم
بفتره قصيره بس انا شاغله مع استاذ حاتم
اعمال قبل من وقت ما تخرجت اول حمره معه
والعراب الجزء الاول والثاني كما كان
استاذ حاتم يعني انا شاغله معه
يعني هيك عملت بس الله يرحمه الله يرحمه
نانسي
النقاد والناس حتى جالسين بيقولوا انه هذه
السنه سنتك يعني الزند
وسفر برلك وقبلهم في ثمن
قبلهم الثمن الثمن مكسره الدنيا الثمن
يعني دحين وقفوه عشان رمضان نشاهد وام بي
سي يعني وقفوه عشان رمضان بس كلنا بنستنى
يخلص رمضان عشان نرجع نشوف نكمل قصه الثمن
انت لما فعلا فعلا نفسك
هذه
استني في شيء عندك في الكونكشن يعني
سمعتك الان ايدي بس من الاول
بقول لك عيدي من الاول انه انتم هذه السنه
خلاص يعني فعلا انت حاسه انها سنتك مع
الثمن
يعني هلا الحقيقه ما بعرف يعني قصدي شو
فكره انه يعني انه فكره انه الواحد يكون
سنته بس يعني هي الاعمال هيك اجت وراء
بعضها والحمد لله هاي الاعمال اغلبها كانت
يعني ما زالت عم تنعرض هلا نزلت عم ينعرض
لسا فكانت عم تلاقي نجاح كثير كبير فهذا
الشيء هيك بيحقق يعني لالي
بيعطيني دفع لقدام للصراحه لحتى اقولوا
بعدين شو بدي اعمل يعني بطريقه طويل هل
صعب اليوميه
يعني
مو النجوميه صعب انه الواحد هيك يضل دائما
محافظ على الاستمراريه الحقيقه كتير صعب
ما بخفيك بدها كثير جهد وبدها صبر وبدها
يعني بدها وقت انا برايي كتير وقت لحتى
الواحد حافظ والاعمال المشتركه بتسهل
الانتشار يمكن اكثر
اكيد اكيد طبعا طبعا يعني الثمن
معنا كثير كبيره ولكن علمت الشخصيه
بخصوصيه انه دائما الشخصيات اللي بتكون
شريره او اشكاليه دغري العالم
بتتذكرها فعلمت الشخصيه وهيك يعني فيها
شيء وانا السعيده فيه هي الاختلاف بين
ثلاث شخصيات اذا بدنا نقول اذا عم نشوفهم
هلا بكم شهر فهو في اختلاف كتير كبير
بيناتهم
واللي انا يعني بيحمسني اني
ضلعوا ابدا بعض العالم انت ما شاء الله
عليك موهبتك ما تحتاجي يعني احد يتكلم
عنها يا نانسي فكل سنه وانت طيبه ودائما
متالقه وبنشكرك كانت معنا من دمشق الفنانه
نانسي خوري شكرا لك ومشاهدينا احنا وصلنا
الى ختام حلقه اليوم في امان الله